I literally expected to enter into a
Kill Bill kind of world where people are
running around with swords chopping each
other's head off with blood flowing in
the streets and things like that
obviously because I didn't know better I
just saw the movies like everyone else
and what I did see was a very different
very much more subtle world which relies
on pressure which relies on appearances
which relies on control much more than
actual violence
[Music]
after ten months of negotiation I was
introduced to the Godfather himself who
you can see is in the middle of the
picture flanked by number two and number
three obviously it was a surreal moment
as the social the number one doesn't
often show himself in public and is
shielded from public by his bodyguards
the boss took the proposal reddit's
nodded a little bit and said okay you
can photograph
[Music]
the structure that I could see within
this Yakuza family or within any Yakuza
for that matter I think is they have a
very very strong urban urban which means
father son in a way relationship very
strict there is a extremely strict
hierarchy number one is boss number two
listens to number one number three I
mean everything is set out basically in
stone and towards the young people and
the new members that are recruited off
the streets they present them as an
alternate family and kind of take them
away from their real blood family to
offer them a better life
[Music]
the Yakuza in Japan are legally
permitted to have a company to unite
themselves so you you do see buildings
in Tokyo with a plaque on the outside
literally saying the name of the Yakuza
which is obviously just a front for the
real business but still nonetheless they
are allowed to do this
[Music]
the tattoos are obviously extremely
important they are the the main visual
recognizable thing about them the the
scenes depicted are for example
something that happened in the life of
the person being tattooed or a character
trait or something like that and it is
depicted through typical Japanese old
myths
they used to meet in uncensored and bath
houses because inside a bath house you
obviously have to be naked so you could
see people could see each other's
tattoos and at the same time could see
that nobody else was carrying a
concealed weapon when somebody is
expected to apologize for something that
you have to cut off a piece of your
finger yourself and presents this little
piece of finger which you have just cut
off on a white napkin to your boss
when they used to fight with samurai
swords the Yakuza the two strongest
fingers are your little finger and your
ring finger and if you would have to cut
off a piece of your pinkie you would not
be able to hold your somewhere.i sword
in battle as well anymore as you would
before now of course it's playing golf
that wouldn't work so well anymore
[Music]
specifically for the Yakuza it is a way
to unite the family and to show also the
the collective mourning because people
of other families would visit the
funeral and people of the family would
be aligned away from the actual casket
to welcome people into paying their last
respects
one of the more intimate moments or was
that I was in the house of the brother
of the deceased of Miyamoto son and he
allowed me to make an image of Miyamoto
son in his coffin but I didn't realize
at the time that this was such a
sensitive thing I only realized
afterwards that I really I think had
made it to to the absolute place where I
wanted to be of trusts coming from them
[Music]